Torii who creates
gems This is very easy to make
a presentation. Let's make a presentation.
Taking advantage of the basic setting that Kanamori put in that birds like glittering things, this bird eats rough diamonds.
You can eat pebbles and put them in the left brain in the back and use them to grind food
. It
's a gizzard of diamonds, but if you eat such a big stone, you won't be able to fly.
Protect yourself from the target with a dash and a kick The swallowed gemstones collide for years in Ino Ward and eventually
become a polished gem head.
It's a
good bird to make. Hey
[Music]
What?  This is a silver jewel and the finger is a thyme bird, but it doesn't have wings. It's not difficult, but there's an
old horse dog. I don't have enough romance.
It's a flower that's hard to see yesterday.